did everyone get the uh
email i tried to send around yesterday
and then representative smith also
turned around about
a second court in the state of new
hampshire
has said that medical marijuana is
permissible for workers compensation
claims i'm i'm guessing that
there'll be some
legislation on it did i just get kicked
off visually
uh nope we can we can see you through my
own computer or just to the
uh both we can see your face and we can
see the room
and the recordings are all set when you
are
i'm just going to chuck in the id one
more time here
good to see you manny back in your
committee
manny oh this is will infantine i don't
want to mispronounce your name
espicia uh it's a heart see so espio
special thank you thank you
here i'm not
sorry guys i'd like to just see
everybody's pretty faces so i have to
try this again who's our clerk
our last session mr chairman
yes i was made aware of that thank you
glad to have him back i'm sure he misses
it terribly
gosh you know alleged admin just doesn't
do it for me
lately
okay it's 901 we're going to start
a session on labor industrial
rehabilitative services
could all stand representative how would
you lead us into pledges
the united states of america thanks to
the republic
for which it stands one nation under god
indivisible with a
i was recently asked why we
had the pledge of allegiance in our
committee and other committees don't
and i can only tell you anecdotally what
i understand it to be
the uh it was when i was here 16 years
ago that's what i was taught
that's what we did and it was more of a
ode to
the men and women that work uh work
in factories work in the fields and and
that was something synonymous with what
they did
i don't know why other committees don't
do that i'm just keeping on the
tradition
that i was i was taught
so with that being said i like to oh you
know what i did guys
remember it's only our last hearing but
i remember
bill 501 mr chairman
representative i believe you have to
read the
uh the disclaimer as to why we're not
all together
in the room thank you michael
i wish it weren't so but so it is
oh it could be a problem michael
may not have brought that file
do you need me to bring you one or do
you want me to send it to you on the
computer
would you please email it to me and i
will read it i will do that now
sorry guys i didn't bring that file
yeah i thought it was all set to go and
which email did you are you going to
send it to christine
my legislative or my individual i'll
send it to your individual
foreign
while we're waiting i'll compliment uh
representative huff on his spring beard
trim
spring is a funny thing here sorry guys
as one likes to point out i am uh
rusty
well this wasn't part of our tradition
when you were here last
all right ladies and gentlemen i will
read the required script
as chair of the labor industrial and
rehabilitative services committee
i find that due to state emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
cobit 19 pandemic
in accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee an executive
session
may follow please note there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in
accordance with the emergency order i am
confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar in the general court
website the notice of this meeting
notice complies with house rule rsa 91-a
anyone who has problems accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600
or email at hcs
ledge.state dot new hampshire dot u s
in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
christine dyer is the staff assisting us
today
please note that all votes that are
taken during the meeting shall be done
by
roll call vote let's start the meeting
by taking a role call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room
with you during this meeting which was
required under the right to know law
mr clark would you please call here in
the legislative office building
see we're here in the lb
uh at work uh employees around
but present tell them
here in the llb myself
here in the lb
good morning i'm here at home alone in
pelham
warden i am here in my home office in
manchester
nobody else here bro
here at home in hudson alone
here llb
at home in my office my wife is upstairs
but not presently
susie here at home and my daughter is in
the house
uh home at my home office um and i'm
alone
uh home in newmarket my wife is upstairs
but
i'm alone in the room this video
here in nashua and i'm here alone and my
wife
fiance is upstairs i am present
and at home alone in my home office
to me here home alone
in nashua bouchard
bouchard
i'm here home alone in manchester
you're loving
all right thank you i'd like to reopen
the hearing on house bill 501
and introduce representative cahill
to introduce his amendments
representative cahill thank you mr chair
um
for the record i am representative
michael cahill representing the towns of
newfields and newmarket
in rockingham 17.
we're back discussing hb 501
a number of amendments some of them kind
of last minute but this is to make it a
little bit
easier for the institutions to comply
what we're asking for
them to do is to provide uh annual
reports
uh on the salaries of not only their
full-time faculty but the adjuncts
and this is because that information
hasn't been available
and we seem to have a problem with uh
with uh salary with low wages for for
uh adjuncts and some and to some extent
the overuse of adjunct
faculty this really
i think this information will help with
uh
people deciding whether they should
pursue that uh avenue
if it's a valid uh uh even as a side
hustle you might do better
delivering for doordash but if this is
your calling and you want to be an
educator you've got the
degrees perhaps you should be earning
more money uh
if this isn't the way to go then you
have to look elsewhere
but that's that's sort of the purpose to
have the information and this is the off
chance
that you know those of us in the
legislature might recognize that there's
a little problem
funding education in new hampshire and
we might actually find a way to improve
that
and every bit of information we have is
helpful i think
so this is amendment um
2021-0614
h and the the change here is that it
no longer asks for 75 of the
compensation of the full-time faculty
it only asks for the annual reports on a
calendar basis
and to be uh no later than march 1st
which is coinciding with
the deadline for w-2 payments so the
information is going to be similar
uh not a terrible burden for the
colleges but we think this will be
useful information
representative cahill what is the
difference between
your amendment 0297h and 0614h
and why are we dispensing with o2 970
uh thank you mr chair
the the thing that's different here is
that in
in the prior amendment we had asked for
the
annual the reports by january 1st that's
it
and and this will move us to move it to
march 1st which will be in
in alignment with the w-2
thank you you did say that and i just
needed to see it visually you understand
um does that conclude your testimony
it does all right well thank you very
much do we have any questions for
representative cato in the lob
if we have any questions for
representative cahill online
get myself the gallery view here so i
can see everybody
uh i have a few questions for you
representative yes sir
it is my understanding that all of this
information
is available to the public now was that
information inaccurate that was given to
me
my understanding is that neither of the
institutions
reports the adjunct only they only do
the full-time if if
they i mean unh does full time but not
the not the adjunct and i don't know of
any reporting done
by the community college system
i'll add that ms reed was going to sign
on today and testify i don't see her
here yet
uh representative i'll go back to the
original uh concern
you have members of the adjunct
professors have a union
the union has been unsuccessful in
negotiating terms that they feel are
appropriate
yet you want the legislation legislature
to provide information
um an effort to make a case
uh to whom or
the um uh the their negotiating team
i i believe this information i mean they
their negotiating team already knows
what they're what they're being paid
so this is really for the benefit of the
general public
and and the legislature
thank you any other additional questions
online
seeing no hands either physically or
electronically
any additional questions here in the llb
seeing none thank you representative
cahill
we have one individual that is signed up
to speak that is tom cronin
state agency staff university system of
new hampshire mr cronin are you with us
christina is there anyone in the queue
yes he's on his way
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee thanks for having us this
morning
um and then i will also note as
representative cahill did i know shannon
is
uh in the queue and has her hand raised
um so i know she has some comments as
well
um so thank you again for for having us
back on this thank you representative
cahill for
for sharing the amendment and kind of
being open on on what you're trying to
do
uh with with this change um so the
university system uh does continue to
oppose this amendment largely because
you know we're unsure
of the objective and to the extent we've
heard the objective this morning we
don't believe that this new
administrative requirement is really
going to provide the kind of information
the sponsors and the supporters of the
original bill might be seeking
uh as a public nonprofit state chartered
entity usnh
is committed to transparent operations
for years we have published annual
salary books
you can find old editions of those books
going back decades
in uh the library at unh and for at
least the last five years and then going
forward they have all been
available online there's no requirement
that we do that in statute
we just think it's good practice we
report in a way that is similar to the
state
which is a point in time snapshot of
base salaries
for all benefit employees as of the date
of the report and for us we report
uh on the last day of the fiscal year so
june 30th i believe
um for years this has generally
satisfied the state and the public
interest and understanding employee
salaries and
i'll just note that last uh back and
forth uh
the sponsor is correct we look like as
he said we report full-time
benefited salaries we do not report
adjunct salaries and we'll get to
kind of some of the reasons why in a
moment however if there's a right to no
request we are a public entity we would
respond to that right to no request as
we have
in the past um the salary book isn't
perfect again it does only
uh it does only show full-time benefited
salary
um but based on this led based on the
prior legislation this amendment we are
having some conversations about
what we could do to perhaps improve some
transparency improve
some reporting to try and get at some of
the concerns perhaps adding an addendum
to that list
that provides annual compensation for
all teaching staff
the the sponsor noted w-2 wages
i think the community college system
does report like that i'll let shannon
speak to that in a minute
we use base salary
again based on what the state does we
think there's also some
kind of perhaps misrepresentation in w-2
data
as it shows wages are impacted by
pre-tax deductions right medical
insurance retirement etc
and i think base salary says this is the
salary for a position
as opposed to w-2 obviously as this is
what jane or john doe made in
a year that said as we begin trying to
add more
detail to these long-running reports we
worry that this information could
continue to create
more confusion for example uh reporting
would not necessarily include the number
of classes taught
by any uh adjunct faculty member so to
the extent that you're trying to get at
what a faculty member is making in wages
or not at least as put out in the
legislation we're not saying this
faculty member taught
three classes and as a result was paid
this we're just saying this faculty
member was paid this so you don't know
if it's for one
three more classes um you also don't
know if that faculty member
is doing other work at either the
university system so we have a number of
employees who may be working part-time
in a range of other
job functions across campus that would
all be rolled into a
w-2 wage reporting so again wouldn't
show you what they're making as an
adjunct faculty member
similar there's faculty that might teach
one class the university system one
class the community college system one
class at a private institution in the
state so again not a great view of
of what they're actually making in the
course of a year um
it i mean it's to the degree that this
and this sort of gets to
to representative cahill's point i mean
we've said from the start of this
conversation that
you know adjunct faculty work is
important it's critical to bring these
additional skills and views into the
university system
um to help students understand kind of
the real world uh experience that these
faculty members are bringing
that's we never intend however for it to
be a full-time position
there are there are there are processes
and pathways for
for faculty to take if they do want to
teach full-time so to the
extent that somebody's trying to make
this a full-time job we understand that
we appreciate it
um but they they are told obviously as
they start this position what the the
pay for a class is
what to pay for any number of classes
based on experience based on the
teaching load etc
um and then send up to that that
individual to make the decision if it
if it's the the path they want to choose
so again we're committed to transparent
operations um
we appreciate that there is an interest
in better understanding this pay
information and would welcome a
conversation
and look forward to working with
representative cahill with some of the
folks that i think he worked with on
developing this legislation
to figure out perhaps a right way to do
this that makes it manageable and it
makes it useful information for
for folks to understand but for the time
being we would respectfully ask this
committee to give us the opportunity to
do that
outside of the legislative or statutory
process
as we have for a number of years and
finally just from a
statutory perspective the university
system and the community college system
are not
governed by the state higher education
commission to my
understanding we do not have any other
reporting requirements to the higher ed
commission
in either of our rsas i would want
shannon i guess to confirm that on the
community college side i can confirm it
from the the usnh side
um so if the committee was interested in
moving forward with an amendment
um that put some sort of requirement in
statute we'd respectfully ask for
a further conversation on maybe the
right way to set up that reporting
requirement
so that's that i'd be happy to take any
questions
thank you your customer you have any
questions here in the llb
i don't see any questions online
unfortunately i keep getting kicked off
on my computer so i'm trying to use my
phone as a backup here so if i miss
again
someone might uh who's online i'll tell
me please
don't see any questions or if hands up
online
thank you mr cronin thank you all very
much
christina do we have any additional
individuals in the queue
we wish you to speak we do have shannon
reed with her hand up
did you say shannon green read
with a d read i'd be wrong you is this
representative reed
shannon reed good morning can you hear
me
yes we can and can you see me
yeah i wasn't quite sure how this was
working this morning
thank you i apologize i didn't sign up
last night um i met too
and i i just didn't my name is shannon
reed i am director of government affairs
for the community college system of new
hampshire
um i'd like to thank the sponsor for
sharing his amendment with us this
morning
i'll do my best to address that that
amendment which i think doesn't differ
too much from the original amendment uh
so
similar to mr conan's testimony there
are a couple different ways of reporting
wages and each has its
um i guess nuances neither is neither is
perfect
ccsnh when we are asked to report on
wages
we we certainly we do so readily we
don't require a right to know request or
anything
um and what we typically report is the
w-2 wage
as mr cronin noted though the w-2 wage
can as easily
misinform as it can provide clarity
because it does have everything bundled
into one
number so i won't repeat the examples
that
that tom provided but it's it's it's
similar for us
um for the community college system it
wouldn't show
the variety of of roles that any any
employee might take on it would
basically show
name primary job title
wages earned during that calendar year
so it really doesn't i think get to the
intent of the bill
um what i think would best meet the
intent of the
of the amendment uh would be we could
report
the salary schedule for adjunct
instructors
which is the the pay that's approved
in the collective writing agreements and
contained in every you know every
successive cba
which would show not linked to a
particular name but it would show
what the pay range is for somebody
teaching a course
at a community college as an adjunct
faculty member
and it would it would kind of indicate
um the differential if it's a lab course
versus a non-lab course
so that would give a clear picture of
what
an adjunct appointment
pays for a given um a given course
um and similarly we could report the
salary schedules
that are in place for full-time faculty
we have a number of those because we
have full-time faculty on 10-month
contracts
11-month contracts and 12-month
so we have a salary schedule for each um
and
again these are things that are
negotiated in the cpas and published
within cbas
but if transparency in some other venue
is what is
sought to my mind those are the most
accurate um the most
that's the most accurate information we
could provide um the w-2 again
very imperfect and could be misconstrued
um and the the type of report that usnh
provides every year
on its public website um captures
salaried positions but wouldn't capture
those adjunct jobs which really aren't
aren't
paid based on an annual salary so i hope
that makes sense and i'll try to clarify
if there's if there's any questions it
looks like the language the amendment
would have us report basically name and
the wages aren't connected with that
name in any given year
but not necessarily you know the intent
of the bill and
perhaps the sponsor can decide that for
himself if he if he thinks that that
would or wouldn't meet the intent um we
have committed
to the bill sponsor that going forward
we will show
on our job recruitment postings for any
adjunct position
that we will post the pay range this is
something we hadn't done
routinely before i don't really know why
it makes sense to do it but
but we we will we'll do that as a
practice
from now on so any adjunct position
that's posted for recruitment on our
website will include
the pay range and that way applicants
will know what level of compensation
they can expect
before they decide whether or not to
apply
um i i guess that's
well i would also um just confirm what
mr cronin shared with you
the community college system does not is
not an entity that reports up to the
higher education commission
as a as a an organization established in
statute
we're accepted from that so we have a
kind of a a whole other kind of universe
of
of public accountability but it's not
through the higher ed commission so this
would be
anomalous if we were to report salaries
in that way
to to that to that commission so i'll
stop and if you have any questions i
will do my best to answer them
thank you very much for your testimony
you have any questions here in the llb
for
miss reed
[Music]
i'm still able unable to connect with my
computer folks that's why i'm using my
temple phone so i'm
sorry uh misread i have a couple
questions um
and unfortunately i'm gonna any of my
committee members who don't like what
i'm gonna say can stop me in any time
because this really isn't a question but
you made an offer
in this in your testing provide
information
um
i would rather not put a law in place
requiring things when we have a
situation here apparently
where we have a dispute
are you will you confirm that you will
provide this information
for the next few years uh as you
suggested um
get requested if you're talking about
if you're talking about the wage
schedules
we already do to our workforce insofar
as they're contained in
cbas um we can certainly
find a i'm certain we can find a way to
put that information
in a public facing way if it's not
already
that would be our salary schedules um
if that's what you're talking about
yes i can commit to that
okay thank you any other questions here
at the lob
any online singing
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you
we have any other members
of the public or legislators wishing to
testify christina
i don't see anyone
thank you for your testimony you know
sweet as i said i don't see any other
people willing to testify
based on that i will close the hearing
unless there's any other questions of
the committee members on this bill i
will
close the hearing on house bill 501
representative cahill i have
repeatedly mentioned i do not like to
exec a bill
on the same day it is heard this is a
rehearing
um on the bill with an amendment
you had indicated last night you would
be willing to to do
something and have it exact today i'm
not going to request that of you that is
your choice
as the sponsor so um
if you are willing to
[Music]
state so now feel free to do so if not
no harm no foul
uh mr chair i i do respect and
appreciate the tradition that you've had
with not exactly the same day
and uh perhaps perhaps it is better not
to rock the boat
and we'll just leave this for another
time
very well um
well mr chair i'd like to if i may add
i'm i'm pleased with the responses we've
had from uh
israeli mr cronin that they're willing
to work toward this without legislation
as was i i appreciate the latitude of my
committee members for letting me ask
jack
right it is 9 30.
we are opening the executive session
[Music]
we have four bills in front of us for
executive session
house bill 113 house bill 261
house bill 517 and house bill 589
fm
i call on um representative mark warden
make a motion on house bill 113.
thank you mr chairman i move the expedia
to legislate
on house bill 113.
you're second seconded by
turcotte you are um
called on to speak emotionally
this is the bill on earned vacation and
we heard a lot of
testimony from different parties that
said it really wasn't needed and
they'd like to leave it up to the
individual employers and
agreements with their employees and
they're just too many myriad agreements
among the
thousands of businesses out there we
don't need to be sticking our government
nodes in this particular aspect of it
it's too hard to do one size fits all
legislation
and therefore this uh this bill is
unneeded
thank you
thank you other
members wishing to comment
please raise your hands any questions or
comments here in the legislative office
building
seeing none any online
representative cahill yes mr chair it's
uh uh i i do have an amendment that
softens a great deal in the glove
for those who those concerns that were
raised previously
and i want to draw your attention that
there are in fact many
people who are doing everything they can
to be good employees many employers who
are also doing
the right thing and it is a matter of
we we don't pass laws for people who are
doing the right things we try to aim
to get more people to do the right
things and
this issue is is really an important
issue for many of our constituents
those who work in businesses and
go along going following the procedure
working their notice
uh doing well and moving on and there is
really no reason
why all when they move on they should
not take whatever they
was given to them as compensation and
then
forfeit it uh simply because the
employer
has this in this policy i'll point out
that when you when you take a vacation
and it comes out of your
whatever it is pto or vacation your
taxes are taken out
your health cut your health care
deductions are taken out because those
are wages
and when you uh when you leave
employment if you if you have vacation
pay and you should you should file for
unemployment
then unemployment is those checks are
delayed until you have exhausted
the money that was paid to you and for
your vacation payout though
in every sense of the word vacation
hours are compensation it is part of
part of what you're given and should not
be retracted uh
just because you've uh made a different
arrangement and are leaving the company
particularly that you're meeting
in good standing with no no bad feelings
or anything like this there is no
justification
for an employer to retain what you have
earned
does that complete your testimony
representative or your your comments
to you it does thank you mr chair
can you see anyone else guys i'm sorry
i'm investing around
this i'm sorry representative smith
you're recognized
thank you um if you'll recall from the
testimony on this
this is a problem with our our labor
department
this is something that they see quite
often that someone who has earned
that money per the agreement that they
have with the company
and the money is being withheld from
them when they leave
even in good standing i think that it's
absolutely essential that we
lighten the load of the labor department
make sure that people are paid what
they've earned
and this has nothing to do with the
government intruding in something it's
got to do with
the businesses following through with
their
promise that's all i needed to say thank
you
thank you representative smith
representative toomey
yeah thank you mr chairman um
my understanding is that this only
applies
to employers who have made a policy
that says that vacation would be
uh granted uh you know
one uh for example uh one month
at a time if if uh
they set up a policy where uh
vacation is earned uh on
on a basis of of one one month at a time
or
or or whatever uh if an employer
does not want to have a policy like that
they're free to do that and this law
would not apply to them so i don't know
if i'm being clear
but this is only to to employers that
have a policy
that vacation is is earned uh
you know at a at a certain sequence of
time
so uh it's no different than when a
employer makes a policy of the employee
you'll be
paid 10 bucks an hour and then all of a
sudden he pays
the employee eight bucks an hour
then of course the labor department
would enforce that
in this case the labor department should
enforce
the fact that the employer has set up a
certain policy
if they don't want that policy they
don't have to have to make that policy
and and so that's that's my uh
view on it so thank you
thank you representative to me i see no
other hands
online okay representative sullivan
online and then representative uh vice
chairman uh
seaworth representative sullivan thank
you mr chairman
um just wanted to point out a couple of
things first of all
i know we're not looking at an amendment
because of the emotion we're uh
dealing with but representative cahill
did bend over backwards to try to
address the issues that people have
raised with regard to this
and um i would have hoped that we would
have had a chance to look at that
amendment
um in addition um one of the issues that
comes up
with lost vacation time is layoffs
employees often have no idea if or when
they're going to be laid off
therefore they don't have the ability to
schedule vacation
prior to that layoff so they're notified
on
right a given friday that um they're
being laid off
and uh the vacation time that they've
got on the books that they were going to
take next month or in two months or at
some point in the future just vaporizes
um and um
that's one of the primary issues i
believe representative cahill was trying
to address here
um so um i would uh ask that we vote
down the uh
uh the motion of itl so that we can
have another motion and look at the
amendment thank you
thank you representative seaworth
thank you mr chairman um
i have been involved with this bill in
attempts to pass it in previous sessions
and something that strikes me today is
one of the things that
bothered me last term when it was passed
and i voted against it last term for
this reason
if you talk to different people which i
have
different members of the committee if
you listen to some of the statements
made today different people have
different
opinions of who this law would affect
and
when um specifically
that and well i don't want to put words
into anyone's mouth because
different people have different ideas
they make statements and i don't want to
try to read into that
i will say that during the public
testimony
i asked some questions of the labor
department based on my reading of the
bill
this bill would apply
to all employers and particularly ones
that
don't have a policy in effect that do
offer vacation
um but don't have certain things in
their policy
and so i asked the labor department
isn't it true that
if there is a written policy and a
worker comes to them and says
my employer violated this policy
they should have done what's written
here the labor department confirmed that
yes
in fact they do have the authority to
enforce the policy
that is in place for that employer
so it concerns me when i hear people
making interpretations of this bill that
differ from my plain reading of it
that differ from the explanation that i
heard from the department of labor
and again i'm going to vote against this
because i i don't think this does
what some of the supporters are saying
it was written to do thank you
any other comments representative of
turcotte you're recognized to speak
thank you mr chairman uh just a couple
of brief comments
one of the questions i asked at the
hearing of a couple of the presenters
who were representing industry
groups were are you aware of any
companies that you represent
that offer vacation days that do not
inform their employees
and the answer to that was no we also
learned that the majority of companies
in in new hampshire
already have a system in place
those who offer vacation time so that's
not an issue
the number of complaints was actually
according to commissioner ogden that
vice missionary was very extremely low
and lastly um once again i know it
becomes it starts to become sound like a
broken record but
there's an employee and an employee
employer
relationship that's cemented when the
the two
individuals get together when the
employer offers the employee
uh the position um
what they agreed to at that time whether
it's through a
union contract or an individual
agreement that should uh that should be
the
way those two handle their business
relationship so i too will be voting
in favor of the ital also i will make
another
quick comment and the idea of
at this point in time receiving an
amendment
i i would suggest
to individuals who like to make
commitments that
in the future if you could do it well
and then
well in advance of uh a hearing
that that would be very beneficial to me
thank you mr chairman
thank you i am going to uh defend mr
cahill here on that last comment
represent cahill uh
shortly after the hearing within hours
representative cahill
asked that i a few other than a few
other people including dave duvet
from the business industry association
meet
within two days we had a a meeting on
zoom
uh with rudy ogden and it was very
beneficial
and we learned some things i do applaud
representative cahill for his tenacity
over the years
um in in trying to get something uh
passed um the um
i know he was trying with the best of
the ability of what we have now
uh to get an amendment to us uh sooner
so i i understand your comments uh i
will uh
give kudos to representative pale for
trying to get things done as soon as
possible
given the circumstances we have with
trying to get things through legislative
services etc
you know um this is a very difficult
situation
bill for me because there are
some circumstances where
some employers have done some things
that
you know to use a vernacular of my
children not cool
um the we had a situation and we were
told by representative ogden
that um at the beginning of the year an
employee gave a yellow piece of paper
to each one of their employees and on
the yellow piece of paper it had how
many hours vacation you have
or how many days and you had to keep
that piece of paper and every time you
wanted
some time off you had to bring that
piece of paper back
and they'd write on it if you lost a
piece of paper well
no more vacation well that's ludicrous
and that was addressed
for the department of labor and they
stopped that i'm aware of certain
circumstances where one company buys out
another
and one company has a lesser
vacation time mechanism than the company
they bought out
um so some employees that well i thought
i had three weeks earned vacation day
because today because i've been here for
five years now all of a sudden some of
the company comes in and says nope we
only have two
so um there are some circumstances um
where the legislature could shore some
things up
the the problem i have with this this
bill originally was
this concept that um which i know the
amendments did take out
uh if you have if you've read these
amendments representative cahill
made a significant effort to take some
of the
concerns that were offered um
during the testimony and make changes to
them um
you know one being you know doesn't
matter if you what you do you beat up
the boss burn the place down you're
still going to get your vacation pay
um so obviously those were what those
were
those are my words see this this bill
didn't say that you all know what i
you know that any any kind of behavior
you would still
get to have your um your earned vacation
pay
this is a lot different than the concept
that we have which if we haven't come
across this yet for some of you
newer folks we have a really strict
belief in the state of new hampshire
that tips are the employees pay
no ifs ands or buts about it and has
never been breached
i'm not sure that the the department of
labor feels the same way
about vacation time the problem is
vacation time is no longer really
vacation time
um many employers give you a block of
time it can be used for vacation
sick personal time or whatever so
what do we how does this affect those
companies
that do not have vacation time per se
uh and if you create something that's
too restrictive on vacation pay people
say well
we're going to get around it by saying
it's not vacation pay anymore it's just
this
lump of time
there are a few things that need to be
adjusted and unfortunately
that's why we have a department of labor
and we have fines associated with these
things
uh i would rather representative cahill
try to come back with a piece of
legislation that talks really about
um different time
because again this would only affect
some it would
not affect many others that don't
adhere to quote-unquote vacation time
so
if you support it as is that's what
representative cahill has outdone
himself trying to
get something palatable for the
committee
[Music]
representative turcotte yeah thank you
mr chairman just to be clear
when i mentioned the timing of
amendments i was under the impression
from
representative cahill and
welsh just mentioned that representative
sullivan mentioned about
taking on another amendment i was
assuming there was
another amendment coming on top of
previous amendments
i thought he was going to introduce yet
another one that was my impression so
that was
just to clear things up okay i
any other comments from the olympia
comments from online representative
cahill
thank you mr chair and i do appreciate
you know your comments and
understanding of the issue uh i'd like
to just point out that you know what
the companies that do pto and say it's
all one all one thing that that has its
own
problems when it comes to things like
the uh
family fed federal family leave act and
i think when people
if people they know they're given a
certain amount of days
and then if they if they take another
company would
imagine the company would keep track of
the days so that they know that
if you've given them 14 days and they've
taken 16
you're not going to pay them for the
other two so i think that's less of an
issue than
we're concerned with and i think that
companies could certainly navigate that
and and that adjustments could be made
in view of however they're looking at it
so that
they really know you know which which is
which
and uh that could be worked out and fine
tuning on
within the employer policy
thank you am i seeing no other
um questions or comments the motion of
the floor
from representative um warning and
second by representative turcotte is
interfering to legislate
yes
i'm sorry if folks wouldn't mind please
saying their name is going to start the
role again please you would say your
name
and then your vote um for the record
please
no no worries no worries
yes myself matthew votes yes
lunas nunez hooks yes
warden order in votes yes
tour card chart madness yes pro
sullivan sullivan votes no
susie susie votes no
rudy rudy votes no
there you go cahill votes no schmidt
sorry schmidt votes no
to me too me votes no
bouchard we had votes now
actually about snapchat
to you expertise snow
even time votes yes quotas
11 to 9.
representative uh the motion uh ipl
passes representative kayla will be
will you be um presenting a minority
blur
uh yes i will thank you thank you
clarify
i apologize um okay
parliamentary here um
will it be ought to pass or ought to
pass the amendment since the amendment
was not brought forth
through committee i believe it has to be
ought to pass as presented i believe
a minority report can include a minority
amendment
correct i believe the motion needs to be
representative cahill
um ought to pass and then
um in your blurb you could mention the
amendment
unless someone parliamentary wise thinks
i'm wrong
with
his motion on the floor would be odd to
pass with the men
is that what you're saying what that is
well wouldn't the amendment
go first you have to adopt the amendment
true but wouldn't this motion on the
floor be off to pass with amendment
no because nobody voted on the amendment
there has to be a vote on the amendment
before chairman infant time would you
like me to reach out to the clerk
and get back to what i was going to
suggest
representative christina yes please in
the meantime representative brudy you at
your hand
yes uh mr chairman i think if that
went like that um you would vote on the
amendment first and then the bill
just like we would do
and the amendment passed or didn't
whatever but i think they'd vote on the
amendment first
the amendment could become a floor
amendment i only think that because
you passed the amendment and then
repealed
it
i'm thinking about from the blurb
standpoint right now the motion on the
blurb
through the majority will be inexpedient
to legislate the minority blurb will be
either
ought to pass or ought to pass with
amendments
i think he can write otp in the blurb
and then reference in the word
he wants an amendment to it that is my
actual standard
i think we should ask the clerk because
he
it gets published encounter and that's
the advantage if it ever comes up
correctly you want to have the minority
amendment published in the calendar
provincial
yeah because it doesn't necessarily have
to be presented in front of this
committee
so i the more i think it out i believe
octopass with the amendment
would be the minority report
but we have time
we've dispensed with our business on
this except just fine
finding out how the blurb is going to be
written
the next piece of legislation uh we're
exact today
is house bill 261 recognized
representative seaworth for a motion
thank you mr chairman i'd like to pass
motion is out to task um see where the
second is by representative
representative seaworth you are um
recognized to speak to your motion
thank you mr chairman um this was a bill
that came with a lot of fireworks
unexpected fireworks
at least from my standpoint
because i didn't realize there was
anything controversial in this bill
it is intended to be a housekeeping bill
that addresses the apprenticeship
council established in rsa
and it takes what that council
actually does and has done
for well over a decade
and adjust the rsa to match
that we heard during testimony
that this is a request from the new
hampshire department of labor
and through them the u.s department of
labor
to bring the law in line with current
practice they testified that since
2007 the office of apprenticeship
at the u.s department of labor has
taken on this
registration and regulation of
apprenticeships
at a uniform national level
and that assume some of the
responsibilities that when this rsa was
originally
written was delicate delegated to that
council
um since that time uh
if an organization
goes to the council is
forming a new apprenticeship program the
council will refer them
to the u.s department of labor program
so uh i hope everyone
can support the on to pass motion
um i i think
having taken the time to understand this
um to to hear about it in testimony and
i know at least i
with the chairman spoke additionally to
the the department of labor
um in between uh to make sure
we understood what this does and what it
doesn't do
and i hope all the members of the
committee
have been able to satisfy themselves
that this
is in fact obvious
thank you representative we have any
comments about the bill
in the lob
seeing none questions online
representative sullivan
thank you mr chair um i just want to
briefly point out that uh
i think the um uh the controversy that
uh
representative seaworth mentions uh was
created by an email that we all received
from someone who
uh felt that this was ruining the um
uh apprenticeship program um
after the the hearing was over um i
think we all got an email i know i did
from that same individual saying oops um
never mind
uh this is this bill's just fine um
so um i i think the controversy was uh
fully unnecessary and um i
i agree with representative seaworth
this is a book uh
bookkeeping uh type issue that we ought
to support
thank you thank you sullivan
believe it or not there was controversy
on the other side
some receipt from a
another trade group that felt that why
are we giving this away
to the feds uh why they we don't like
them dealing it we should deal with it
here ourselves not realizing that this
has
been the situation since 2007. as brian
outlined he and i did have a zoom
meeting with both the commissioner and
assistant commissioner of labor
we still do have a commission that does
meet they meet once a year
like they did prior to
the feds taking it over in 2007
not much to talk about in their meeting
because everything has been copacetic so
far
the reasoning behind the the difference
between having it run at a local level
versus on the federal level
is um kind of reciprocity um you know
if if a group has a an apprenticeship in
texas and one in florida and one in new
hampshire
and someone in new hampshire is only
going to move to texas or florida
they want to make sure they're utilizing
the same standards for the
apprenticeship
and any of you who are licensed in
anything know that there's a lot of
reciprocity in
amongst licensed people that are
licensed in certain industries
amongst many of the states and this
facility made that
much more easy so um
there were there was controversy on both
sides someone wanted us to take it back
not give it away how dare we give it
away to the feds so
um all said and done it looks like it is
as advertised
a simple word updating of some of the
language
to consistent with what we're doing now
any other additional comments here in
the legislative office building
saying none any online
none mr clark did the motion on the
floor is not to pass
could you please roll the call call the
roll and members please
uh state your last name and your vote
see what votes yes
votes yes
yes rudy rudy vogels
j-hope hay hill votes yes
schmidt schmidt yes
to me give me votes yes
bouchard
yes
zero in favor without objection we will
add this to the consent agenda
see no objection thank you
house bill 516 representative
um you're
recognized excuse me
which one
uh thank you speaker uh let's go 517 i
make a motion to
retain second of our representative
puff you're
recognized to speak to your motion thank
you mr chairman
we know there's a lot of things going on
on the federal level with potential
changes to
uh minimum wage rates um there's a lot
of other issues
within this bill itself that normally
that would actually be itl but uh
for the time being i'm uh i think it'd
be
in the committee's best interest to
retain until at least uh next year
thanks
thank you mr chairman um i want to
start off by saying um i i think
what is going to happen on the federal
level is pretty squared away
um some of my least favorite democrats
have uh
made that situation a little difficult
so i don't think that's going to end up
being the reconciliation package
i think that's going to be you know up
to states to decide
um and speaking of states
uh one of the things that i really wish
we had to answer was
ballot initiatives because they tend to
supersede the legislature that this
occasion a little disconnected and we
saw
what i thought was a pretty effective uh
ballot initiative in the state of
florida
in 2020 and i brought this up in the
hearing but i wanted to expand a little
further
um in florida in the 2020 election
they had a ballot initiative for a
constitutional amendment
for a 15 an hour minimum wage prior to
that the minimum wage in the state of
florida was 8.25
and with 61 percent of the vote they
passed that ballot initiative and that
was a state
in 2020 that was won by president trump
with 51
of the vote uh 5.6 million votes
uh the minimum wage got 6.5 million
votes
so a million more votes than
the republican presidential candidate
that year meaning that there had to be
some broad bipartisan crossover in order
for that to be possible
it was so popular that it even beat
president obama's numbers in 2008 where
he got 51
of the vote in the state of florida and
minimum wage got two million more voters
in the state of florida than uh that
year
meaning that a 15 an hour minimum wage
in the united states is more popular
than any politician that has run profits
in the last 20 years
in 1950 president harry truman one of my
political idols
doubled the minimum wage from
75 cents to 1.50 an hour
and like in truman's time there were
adverse feelings about raising the
minimum wage
he said of his political opponents at
the time that they believe in a minimum
wage the more minimum the better
in 1950 unemployment was 6.6
um right before in the month before that
minimum wage increase went to effect
in december 1951 the unemployment rate
was 3.1
and in december 1952 it was 2.7
no study that has that doesn't have a
predetermined bias
will say that the minimum wage destroys
the economy
when truman doubled the minimum wage it
had the buying power
of 13 an hour in 1950.
there's an argument that it'll raise the
cost of goods and i don't believe that's
the case
because if you look at france there's a
minimum wage of 13
an hour and a big mac at mcdonald's
costs 452
in australia the minimum wage is closer
to 19 an hour
and the big mac is 465. and the united
states and in new hampshire
the minute the minimum wage is 7.25
cents an hour
and the big mac is 479. we all got an
email the other day
from the new hampshire federation of
independent businesses
and one of the lines in that email said
uh we all know minimum wage wasn't meant
to be a living wage
i have no idea where this pernicious
idea came from
because the father of the minimum wage
president franklin roosevelt
specifically said that the minimum wage
was meant to be
a decent standard of living and not just
a bear assessments
because what is the point of having a
minimum wage if folks that work it can't
survive
roosevelt like truman knew that you
didn't water a tree on its leaves
you water it at space many small
businesses already paid good wages
but many large businesses are the ones
who force their overworked and underpaid
employees onto the government roles
and that's corporate welfare plain and
simple there was also a point in that
email that said
the legislature shouldn't interfere in
the relationship between labor and
management
and not only do i want to remember that
when a
certain senate legislation comes over
and i might fundamentally disagree with
some folks and that's perfectly fine i'm
happy to do so
but the simple fact of the matter is for
me
that somebody has to stand up for labor
the relationship with those who work and
those who hold the goods
is not an equal one in a world where
folks have to work
this is the longest period of time that
the us has gone without a raise
and i think it's time to change that and
i want to end on one more
quote from president truman that i think
is valuable to the conversation
when he doubled the minimum wage he said
in the 1949 state of the union
quote we have rejected the discredited
theory
that the fortunes of the nation should
be in the hands of a privileged few
we have abandoned the trickle-down
concept of national prosperity
instead we believe that our economic
system should rest on a democratic
foundation
and that wealth should be created for
the benefit of all
minimum wage fixed by law should be
raised to at least 75 cents an hour
and that is what i'll conclude my
testimony with
i would ask that to retain motion be
not um that be shot down
and remove otp
thank you any other questions any other
comments here in the llb before i go on
so you know i have a few hands
representative sullivan followed by
representative bouchard
thank you mr chairman i'll be uh
relatively brief because i think uh
representative adjutant has
said most of what needs to be said um
and said it well
um the um um i guess you'd start off by
asking um if we retain this bill um
are there members of the committee um in
the majority
who will help to uh work in the bill to
make it acceptable to
um uh the full full body on in the house
i'll i'll leave that there but i i
wouldn't
i think it would instruct my vote um to
know that we are actually going to work
on it not just sit on it
and secondly um i just want to say that
um a few years back when the um
a fight for 15 uh was first
uh invented or suggested um
a 15 minimum wage was a fairly radical
idea
and i think i think it had shock value
at the time
um a 15 minimum wage is no longer
the least bit radical it is mainstream
um it is being
passed as uh the representative just
pointed out by
states like florida um and um
i think it's time for new hampshire to
join the mainstream
and get its uh eventual 15 minimum wage
passed um so i'm i'm sitting on my vote
at the moment wondering if uh there's
going to be any indication that this
will
be worked on by the majority of the
committee
i'll answer that question when my turn
comes around representative bouchard
um i just want to add to thank you mr
chair
i just want to add to josh's
eloquent uh advocacy for
voting for increasing the minimum wage
because
i'm going to vote for the increase
because i believe that no one who works
40 hours a week should struggle to put
food on their table
and pay their rent however too many of
our families are struggling
to make ends meet while working two or
three jobs
i believe that many businesses find that
raising wages increases productivity
reduces turnover and improves morale
it is common sense that workers with
more income are likely to have access
to more reliable transportation to work
child care health care and reducing
absenteeism i also believe that it costs
new hampshire taxpayers money
to provide basic needs when businesses
pay their workers
far less than a living wage house bill
is not a living wage however it will
reduce the need for workers applying for
safety net programs
provided by the state thank you
thank you representative bouchard
representative smith
thank you mr chairman uh last time we
talked about this we talked about the
wage calculator at livingwage.mit.edu
and i hope everybody's had a chance to
just glance at that because
if you don't have the data that's in
there you only have half of the
information
you need to make a good decision on this
bill
um if you've looked at it you see that
you're not going to find a place
for 800 a month you're you're um
you're going to spend more than ten
dollars a day on food
um an online certificate for southern
new hampshire university
is over nine thousand dollars that isn't
even covered on this
i'm not sure that the people who grew up
with me or
shortly thereafter remember that
we could work a summer job and um
serve tables uh between classes
and make enough money to go to college
people today
can't even put food on their table they
have to call the welfare department they
have to go to the soup kitchen
people with jobs 40 hours a week
or more many times more can't even get
the basics
and that's just crazy in a state
that's one of the richest in the country
that we
keep people at such a low income
that they can't even participate in our
society
i want you to think about money like oil
in an
engine it's going to work best if the
money continues to circulate
that it comes to the people who are
going to spend it
they can buy shoes for their kids they
can go to grocery stores they can go
out to eat and that all of that means
jobs
this isn't just one person getting a
bigger paycheck
this is that money going into the
community and that's
really really the reason that we're
talking about
getting a minimum wage set and start on
a way up for prosperity
for everybody thank you very much mr
chairman
thank you representative smith
do i see any other hands
i do not see any other hands online i do
not see any hands here
um i will answer your question
representative sullivan um
but i want to start off with the fact
that um very well spoken
probably hadagen but i don't agree with
you that things are dead
in washington uh the reconciliation
package that both new hampshire or state
senators or not
u.s senators voted against adding the
minimum wage
um to the stimulus package um
there's an article um a study that finds
that a 15
minimum wage will cost 1300 granite
staters their jobs
um the
concern is the too significant an
increase
employers who are just coming out of the
covid situation will
choose to reduce uh wages uh
instead of having weight staff they'll
have computer tablets and
a number of these different things uh we
currently have a 3.6
unemployment rate in new hampshire
that's up from 2.6
uh but given what we've been through the
last 12 months
um we're doing very well here in the
state of new hampshire
it is almost impossible to find
employees for certain jobs i can't speak
for the arrest
the rest of the state i can only speak
for what i see when i drive around
the manchester uh concord area
there are businesses um offering
unskilled employees from 11.50 to
13.50 an hour to work at fast food
restaurants
not a glorious job but this guy right
here
uh was the assistant manager to burger
king i saw my burger king thai
while i was working for an insurance
company i worked two jobs
um so i've done the job um
so i you know and both my daughters that
are college students
make significantly more than
seven dollars and 25 cents an hour
so right now i would say these
these companies are having a hard time
filling their positions between 11 and
an hour to answer your specific question
representative sullivan
um i was uh basically uh
tarred and feathered for offering
through this committee about 10 years
ago
two 50 cent increases in the minimum
wage over a two-year period
uh back to the time uh i thought we
could at least increase it a little bit
based on the fact that so many employers
are offering such a higher
starting salary or starting wage per
hour
the issues that i specifically have
representative sullivan for this bill
are
are threefold uh number one um i'd like
to increase the minimum wage this is my
personal belief
not shared by many members of my party
um that a five dollar
increase is significant and maybe too
much
uh in one foul school i however do like
the increase
over a period of years
one non-starter for me representative
sullivan is
an adjustment of the minimum wage by
consumer price index
an older gentleman 10 years ago told me
that legislators don't let things happen
automatically they must
stand behind their vote whether to
increase something or to decrease
something but they shouldn't rely on an
automatic increase
so i wouldn't be able to support that
there is a bill coming forward
which i believe has the support of the
democrats as well as senator soucy
coming from the senate that will come to
us that separates the minimum wage for
tipped employees versus non-tipped
employees because that always is the rub
every time we increase it
uh increase it whether or not you're
talking
all the employees or just the tip versus
non-tip which would allow this
legislation ability to make
um a difference between the two this one
increases the tipped wage to
um fifty percent which is
something i i don't see as necessary and
lastly
the part of the bill that says anyone
under the age of 18 years ago
age shall be eight dollars per hour for
the first six months of employment
while i understand the sponsor's goal
they're trying to look at what we call
something we already have in new
hampshire which is a training wage
um but someone who graduates from high
school
early at 17 years of age 17 and a half
going out trying to make a living and
you're they
there shouldn't be this just doesn't
mesh i understand what they're trying to
do but i don't think this is very good i
think this actually hurts
what you're trying to do um
representative smith i take a little bit
of exception with a statement you made
and
i don't think you meant it to be mean or
anything um
you said keep people at a low income
um i don't think that's fair i don't
think anyone here who is voting
in favor of this
being retained wants to keep anyone at a
low income
i know this legislator does not
wages are higher um than the seven
then the current minimum wage i think
everyone needs to
acknowledge that the same way i could
acknowledge that it may be too low
so will we work with it yes do i believe
that a minimum wage will be coming out
of washington d.c
yes i think it will be ten dollars now
or something like that the
democrats have the votes in the senate
and the house to do this
um they should do this
um and um maybe 15 is a
little too far for them but they should
at least come up
with something that all members of the
united states congress and senate should
be able to deal with
again each one of those congressmen and
senators are dealing with different
areas of the country
so but i think they should do that as
well so i hope that answers your
question representative sullivan about
my issues
um as is representative sullivan i would
itl this bill because of the items i
specifically just outlined i would like
to retain it
and see what happens on a federal level
but again i am in the minority in in the
uh
in my party regarding the the minimum
wage
um so those are
my comments for whatever they are worth
representative turcotte thank you
i wanna i'd like people to kind of think
about something this was a kind of a
an example i brought up four years ago
we were going through a similar bill
um at the time both my kids
uh were at home and uh
i think it's very instructive as to the
effects of the minimum wage i think too
many people
they don't look at the the economics of
it or
or what happens when you institute a
minimum wage
uh random with minimum wage here's the
example
at the time my son was making 15.50 an
hour
working for a landscaping company he
busted his butt he would get up at 5
30 in the morning and he would get home
at six at night
sometimes later working out in the hot
sun and the
freezing rain it didn't matter you know
he'd work 50 60 hours a week busted as
much that would make a lot of money
15.50 an hour at the same time my
daughter was working
at a as an ice cream scooper at a little
place down in york beach maine
she made 825 of them she made a little
more because she got tipped
she would get up at 10 in the morning
saunder down and then work from 11
to say six at night fight the different
set of jobs
but let's just run through a scenario
now what happens when
she now is mandated to get 15
an hour she gets 15 an hour
not only does that increase all the
business costs
cost of ice cream everything at that
business but what happens
to the landscape company now
with that who's paying my son 15.50 an
hour
if you've got a job where you can go
scoop ice cream for 15
an hour or go bust your butt 68 hours a
week for 15.50
what's going to happen i'll tell you
what's going to happen either
my son is going to go find an easier job
for 15 an hour which you wouldn't do
because that's not how he is
or the landscape company now is going to
have to boost
that starting pay to get people to work
there
it's not going to be 15.50 an hour
anymore now it's going to be 20
22. an hour to get individuals to go to
work
in that type of environment then play
that out
what happens what happens to the
landscape
company all right they have to start
charging more because they're paying
their
their employees and it's just this
leviathan of the everything that is
impacted by setting an average
arbitrary minimum wage not something
that's set by the free market
or supply and demand um that's that
example
you know i every time we talk about a
minimum wage or a living wage
i always hear somebody can't survive and
get an apartment for x amount or this or
that
you know i look back that the chairman
made some comments about that how he
started out
i started out the same way um
we didn't at age 20 living in atlanta i
couldn't afford to go out and buy my own
uh apartment i lived with five other
guys so we could afford
to live um one of my first girlfriends
when i lived in new york for a while
she and five girls lived in a studio
apartment
in new york because that's the only way
they could afford
to live they made it happen they didn't
each expect to have their own
1200 1500 apartment they made
choices they made choices they wanted to
be a flight attendant for american
airlines so they made the choice
to do what they had to do to make that
happen um
mr chairman um representative
i respect you and i think you're an
honest actor um
and that's why i just fundamentally
disagree with you i think
um when we talk about um the stuff i
mentioned in my testimony
preempted i think some of the things he
said because i've just heard
a lot of that stuff over and over again
every time we talk about the minimum
wage
uh one of the things that you mentioned
was uh sort of the rising tide argument
um where you know if you're paying
somebody a low skilled worker
a little bit more um then that's going
to raise the cost of everything
i think i talked about that when we
talked about the price of goods
uh in 2009 when the minimum wage was
still 7.25 an hour
um you know cost of fast food was a
little bit less
or it was considerably less than it is
now i think it was just when we used the
big mac example
you know that hamburger in 2009 cost
about three dollars
it's getting up closer to about five
dollars now so even when that wage has
an increase
because of the cost of inflation
generally that good has
gone up so i don't think that had
anything to do with the minimum wage
necessarily
when you talk about you know uh in times
past
folks working for a little bit less uh
one of the arguments in dc
by senator thune uh was well when he was
a kid he made six dollars an hour
and uh you know that should be fine when
senator thune was working for six
dollars an hour the minimum wage had the
buying power of 24
an hour which really i think leads into
the inflation point
um you know we're talking about a 15
increase over the course of five years
like who knows what the value of the us
dollar is going to be in five years with
you know passing stimulus bills where
trillions and trillions
of dollars from the federal reserve are
pumped into the economy that's going to
increase inflation just and
uh it's going to make that dollar worth
less so
it's going to be more expensive in order
to survive
in five years when you have an age i
think the 15
hour minimum wage is already a pretty
good compromise you know
based on the cost of living i didn't
vote for the 22 one
but i do think that 15 is a good solid
four in five years from now
and you know i i i always hear the
argument
um well you know an emt is making 13
an hour so why does a you know burger
flipper think that they get to make you
know 15
an hour i guess my question is why is an
emt making 13
an hour you know an emt is a pretty pain
in the neck job
very stressful very difficult for those
folks and i want
that emt to have the power to go to
their employer and say hey
i could go get a job you know flipping
burgers even though i think that's
you know fairly difficult job standing
over the hot stove all day and dealing
with
you know not very nice customers uh what
are you going to pay
i think it gives them a little more
flexibility in their employment
it gives them the opportunity to
threaten their employer that they'll go
somewhere else
um and again as i said in my testimony i
fundamentally believe
that it is our responsibility to stand
on the side of labor
so that's the rest of that
representative i must admit i apologize
you were supposed to make the motion and
i made a mistake but representative
that's
it's very difficult to hear the
representative
please okay
thank you representative can you hear me
now much better thank you
thank you um
as i was starting to say i would since
everybody is uh this is a hot topic
and folks want to uh expound on it uh
their their views
and i appreciate that i would feel
remiss if i didn't point out
just a couple of things that i believe
i understand everybody's concern
for a living wage i understand how
folks want to make sure that things go
the way that they want them to do it
the problem is and the part that nobody
seems to be addressing
is um as uh representative adjutant
pointed out uh
affairs in florida they're not germane
to this bill
he spoke about 1951 and what was going
on there
again not germaine the prices of big
macs
in australia
not jermaine what is germaine is that in
a free market society
which we have at the moment
laissez faire is what goes on
there is absolutely no place
for government to take the side of
either the employer
or the employee period
that's just the way it is the market
decides
hearing some of the folks um who are in
favor of this
they keep referring to what uh somebody
should make or how they should make it
i suggest they open a business and pay
them that
instead of trying to force the
government to force other folks to do it
plain and simple this is not something
the government is should be involved in
it should be allowed we as government
should allow
folks to do what they do which is free
enterprise
that's my two cents except i would want
to also point out
um one of the things that's been being
said
is that um an incremental increase
would be a better thing let me just give
you a small little
uh anecdotal story if i have a lobster
and i have a boiling pot of water and i
throw it in
it's dead if i have a pot
and i put a lobster in and turn the
water on of the heat
on it's still dead as is this bill
and i will not support it in any form
thank you
so much one more comment um
yeah i mean if we're talking about the
non-germaness of 1951 the only
non-german part of that i'd say
is that this country used to have
something called price control
you know in uh roosevelt truman's time
it was a little bit easier to afford to
live in the united states
housing costs were less um cost
healthcare was a little bit less
um we're talking about an expensive
society of living nowadays
and that's the only non-germane element
of that that i would say
representative representative turcotte
mr chairman going to talk about
germain no or not
i think it's simple if we're going to
talk about
times when i was actually alive and
still can remember
then we must also say if it's germaine
then certainly the gold standard is
germaine
so all of that back then
there was no inflation because we had
real gold
and real silver i don't know how many
others
in this committee can remember those
days
and i may be the eldest eldest one here
but i remember them and we went year
after year
after year without any inflation this is
all
all caused by lack of
gold and silver and the fact that we
just print money and then we're
constantly chasing our tails
so how many people can remember when you
paid your babysitter with
silver i so i'll be voting against it
thank you president thank you mr
chairman uh
something representative huff reminded
me of a uh
another great example of a force
15 an hour a several of you who were
still on the committee i think a few
years back when we were going through a
similar bill we had the owner of
the seventh settlement brewery and
restaurant in dover
come and testify uh my wife and i used
to go there quite often it was always
great the
beer was good the food was great awesome
service
and then one day the owner decided that
he was going to pay all his
employees 15 an hour whether you were
the dishwasher
a server bartender whatever
and there was going to be no tipping so
everything was going to be fair at the
seventh settlement brewery and
restaurant
my wife and i went back uh not long
after he testified before this committee
and hum
humans being as they are when you're
everybody's making the same
we can i can tell you the effort and the
service from the servers that were there
now making 15
an hour rather than maybe 20 to 25 that
they had making as attempted
wage earners were now not quite as
attentive
within a few months after that the
restaurant
shut down and then a few months after
that
the brewery shut down so it wasn't i
think it was less than a year from the
time he implemented
the 15 same wage for everybody the
place was out of business a once great
place because
he wanted to however you want to
describe it be fair
whatever it wanted to be it ended up
killing his own business
thanks
thank you mr chairman um
[Music]
a couple things um first of all
i don't disagree with anything that uh
representative edgington has
stated um
secondly um i like most of what's in
this bill
[Music]
and would gladly vote for it um that
motion is not on
before us um
third thing um
[Music]
mr chairman you've never given me reason
to um
not trust you um i think uh
that's very important and um if you're
saying that you will work on this bill
um for next year
if no other bill passes this year
because there will be others you're
right
um um i will work with you
and i will vote to retain the bill
thank you very much i actually think
that we're not done with minimum wage uh
regardless of what happens in the house
because we have crossover and we have
uh the feds will act
i'm sure before we are done here so it
may be attached to it as
a bill that's just my my guess
representative rudy thank you mr
chairman
um i appreciate the words that you said
before
of all um minimum wage bills i've seen
this one is one i think we can all work
with
and um i hope we can go forward and i'm
i'm probably gonna vote to retain it too
so we can work on this together
thank you thank you
seeing no other hands in the lob
or online i'm going to ask
the uh let's call the roll the motion on
the floor
is to retain house bill 516
at least uh when called on state your
name and your
vote stewart seaworth
yes
representative abelani yes
general yes myself
yes new news representative nunez votes
yes
jordan warden yes
turcotte trick i guess
[Music]
wrote yes boyd boyd yes
oh yes
sullivan what votes yes
susie lucy vote yes
rudy voting vote yes
there you go cahill votes yes
schmidt schmidt votes yes
tell me about yes bouchard
this side vote yes accident
action votes now spca
espithia votes uh yes
thank you time you've been talking about
jeff
um
vote is on 1921 yes
um the next bill in front of us i'm
i want to talk freely with the committee
members
it is house bill 589
required workers compensation to cover
uh prophylactic treatment for critical
exposure
it was my initial desire to
pass this ought to pass and
the republican members of the committee
had a caucus
and during the caucus a number of items
were brought up with inconsistencies
with some of the other bills that were
passed was this
really for all employees or is it just
for first responders
and a number of things it was our
determination
that this would uh bill be retained
there's some disagreement between
[Music]
opinions on the
interpretation of the amendment
that has been presented and
while it was my intent to come in here
and ask the committee to retain
the bill we are going to have to come
back into this committee
again uh before we are done
and um i would rather
dispense with this correctly versus
retaining it and have it wait another
year
but it is not
i don't feel the republican members of
the committee can pass it the way it is
there are just too many issues with with
some of the things and misunderstanding
i'll take responsibility for this
because i
either misread the initial bill and i
was all set to go and rock and roll um
representative cahill
i'm going to ask my committee members
and again i don't know how
we're not i don't know how appropriate
this is
um we do have to come back
i would like to present all of our
concerns to representative cahill
um to let him come back since we do have
to come back
on this
and if the time we still are not
convinced we can still retain the bill
this is contrary to what was agreed to
with my caucus members
um so i kind of throwing this at him and
i apologize
it was just something that
my the vice chairman submitted to me
in a piece of paper he presented to me
and now i'm just very confused and i
can't vote on something
that i'm confused on um
is there any objection and
and please be honest with me
because we do have the ability to have a
motion on the floor
to retain the bill
if they're willing to allow since we do
have to come back anyway
represent vice chairman this is a
procedural question
um given the hesitancy to move
into an executive session
despite the fact that we didn't notice
which would allow us to discuss the
issues
without
i don't really think we can because we
didn't notice it
and i wouldn't want to push that
representative turcotte
chairman i think uh maybe a caucus would
be hard
i i agree and but i don't know how we do
that
um we can go to another room and we can
have a few of the people online call in
we can uh eliminate the video we can
turn the microphones off
on the zoom and we can ask a
representative
adjutant to leave and that would give us
the entire room to our service
will you have republican members on the
caucus we're on the call
mr chairman um just a moment
we can um
we can do what we've done before i can
utilize
a conference call call-in number on my
cell phone
for the republican members to call in
um and um we can have that here
caucus i would like to i would be my
take down
on that representative sullivan um
i was going to offer that um if we're
going to caucus obviously the democrats
will caucus also
we would do what we did last time we
would sign off
of the current zoom and sign onto
a separate one and
if you wanted to utilize the zoom you
could simply call me
when you're ready for us to come back in
well i'm gonna um ask everyone to come
back into the main
zoom at 11 15.
um i will um
i will get the caulk um we'll turn off
the zoom feed here
we'll come back in 25 minutes
republicans in the room
and then i will um get the
conference call number ends you won't
have to do the conference call if all
the democrats are going to leave the zoo
we are not
supposed to do this but we can't
yeah so i'm going to um have
a conference call
three or four republicans so they can
call in is that acceptable
representative sullivan
yes we will sign back in at 11 15 as you
suggested
thank you
democrats sign in on the
same one we used yesterday yes
[Music]
i guess i'll put us this way
when when the uh
guys there's lots of there's lots of uh
feedback
does it automatically reset when you
cross time zones
or when we change our seasons yes
christina can you hear me yes i can you
sound great
shhh
are we missing a couple people here
christina
mr chairman president
yes i've uh i've asked rudy ogden to
join us to help clear up the question
about whether this is for first
responders only
i believe it is
well i'm sorry kale you probably should
ask me about that first
um because uh you know we're not in a
session where we're gonna
oh okay i i thought that you might be
able to help us with the
questions but if excuse me for
overstepping
no i'm sorry sorry um i would ask
uh i apologize for calling these little
ruckus here guys but i um
we have a situation where we have a bill
that everybody would like to pass
the problem is we have a number of
questions here
that we're not going to be solved today
because even if we have rudy ogden
answer a bunch of questions
we're not going to be able to have an
amendment here
so i would ask
everyone to bear with me
and listen to what is going to be
offered
i'm going to open up a session
on house bill 589
589 fn requiring works conversation to
cover
prophylactic treatment and call on
representative huff for a motion
uh thank you mr chair i motioned to
retain uh
house bill 589
so is that second oh second second about
representative callum
president uh thank you mr chair
uh given the confusion
that the committee is having on content
language um
and even while we're in caucus there was
still
quite a bit of confusion we want this
bill to be right
we appreciate its intent we just want to
make sure that we have the opportunity
to get this right
we're going to look for clarity the
chairman will
expound on that a little bit further and
also we just want to make sure that the
public
isn't confused we just want to make sure
that they can get in and talk about
the issues as such so that's that's
basically it
thank you to
members of the committee i don't want
this bill to wait
for an entire year but based on our
initial conversations based on all the
conversations we just have there's no
way i'm
going to be able to be comfortable where
this side is going to be comfortable
so what i would like to do is i would
like
representative cahill and i to work
together with rudy ogden in the next
couple weeks to come up with an
amendment
to this bill and then if we are all in
agreement
um i would ask the senate
to attach it to a bill that comes over
to us a crossover so we can have it
this session um i think we can find some
bills that are coming over where we
could find a tremendous to it
to bring it over but
i don't have the ability in the next two
weeks
to have another hearing have this put
together
uh and then i will recognize
representative proud who's going to
speak on just some of the issues
that we're concerned with so you
understand
but in doing so i just wanted you to
know
that i'm willing to do this with
representative cahill
so this does not have to wait a year uh
we can hopefully
attach this to something else
representative proud
thank you mr chairman uh so my big
concern is
clarity if we've really gotten the right
feedback on this bill
um the title of the bill references
prophylactic treatment which
i think naturally leads one to look at
the
um the definition uh in the same section
as the other definition
but in uh 14a about post-exposure
prophylactics which cross-references
definition 1e
critical exposure which is what this
bill really the meat of what it modified
however that 1e critical exposure is
also used in another section as well
and we didn't talk about that other
section and what the changes would do
over there
if anything and it's really wasn't
perfectly obvious that it would have
changes outside of
really the section we focused on for
first responders
the fiscal note also focuses a lot on
the municipal association leading one to
believe that this
the major effect is regarding first
responders and all that makes me
concerned if we really got the right
feedback that we should have gotten on
this bill uh
if i was misled at first by reading that
took well to realize the bill could have
effects outside of just first responders
i'm wondering if other interesting part
interested parties may have missed it as
well
and i really want to make sure that we
fully understand what the effects on
that other section because the
definition is used in multiple places
what those effects are and if anything
and really fully understand that before
we move forward
thank you mr like any other comments
here
in the lob
online
representative sullivan
thank you um i'm wondering from a
procedural standpoint
um whether we could
uh do that same work we don't have to
vote on this today
and we are coming back to vote on
another bill we've got another bill to
exec
and so um you could do the same work
that you were suggesting with uh
rudy ogden and representative cahill and
then bring it back to
um this committee
to vote on when we did do what is it 500
not yeah 501 we've still got to exec 501
so and then we could just send it to the
senate in a normal
fashion rather than i mean
what you're suggesting could work but
it requires cooperation from the senate
which we don't always get
so what about just working on it
and bringing it back for exactly with an
amendment
i will respond to that uh since you
asked me a question but i'll take
any other comments first please
no other comments online
all right representative sullivan it was
always my understanding that this bill
was supposed to be for first responders
uh that was the way representative white
first proposed it
now with representative cahill six years
ago or five years ago i believe
specifically because of an incident that
happened up in lebanon where he was a
first responder this bill
is for anything for any
office any factory anything
i don't believe that was the intent
of this legislation um
if
that if
the title in in the guts of the bill
are different because it's not just what
we're looking at this this is what got
us all
confused if you just look at the bill
itself
okay it's pretty straightforward
and i'm guilty of reading it briefly
saying yep yep i got familiarity with
this yep there's just a couple things
here this thing looks fine
but then you have to correlate it back
to 281 and some of the other items
and that's where it gets fuzzy
because this is not for first responders
so i guess my first question is is that
was this incorrect or was that a bait
and switch
not intentional or intentional whatever
i would do i would assume it was not
intentional
so we have intended for first responders
right well that's
we have three people that say um it's
only for first responders and seven
saying no
you have to look back in 281 you gotta
look at number six and uh
rsa281 a6 823 you have to go back to all
these different things
and whether it was incorrectly
presented by legislative services i
don't
know um the
the question is is the time
representative
um we are all faced with a lot of things
of what we're trying to all get done
you know you don't pay me enough to make
these decisions
um
the caucus um was um
was um opinion
and the motion on the floor is what it
is um
has retained and i can't guarantee we're
all going to come up with something we
like in two weeks and i would
i'm giving you the best option i can
which is trying to keep it alive this
session
and not next year because i don't want
to go through as bro as my
vice chairman said to me i don't want to
go through another summer
uh trying to figure this out we all want
it
we ought to do it the the right way and
[Music]
the time constraints and other things um
you know this is going to require
more than than representative cahill and
i rudy and ogden
to sit down deal with these things go
back to each one of our caucuses come
back bring it back to make sure we all
have the right amendment
and i just not confident that can be
done in the time frame that we have and
that's why we
promote the motion we have
representative cahill
thank you mr chairman and you know from
the legislation there was a reference
91 something or other that said it was
perspective for first responders and
that's what
uh i and i'm sure ols had in mind when
we were the only offending problem
was this issue of having the saliva be
visible and insufficient magnitude which
was kind of undefined
so that's the only thing i changed i
i believe it really is and still uh
for first responders that certainly was
my intent
and i would hope that we could find a
way to make that crystal clear
for anyone who was in doubt and but i
would welcome the opportunity to do that
in whichever
venue you feel is appropriate
i i don't want to have to come back with
this uh i think my police chief and town
manager are getting a little tired of
this being an issue every year
i know that they don't like paying for
uh workers
comp uh insurance and then having to pay
claims that are denied
uh and i'm pretty sure the municipal
association would view this in the same
way
so yes i agree with you that we should
get it done and
uh if if a work session uh and an
amendment can't be done
uh then then retained would be the way
um
[Music]
i don't know if if you uh i don't know
if
mr ogden might have a word of wisdom to
uh to clarify this up
almost instantly or if that would be
allowed
i think we're gonna if i if we start
getting into this it's gonna be a work
session which i'm not sure
we are allowed to do right now it's one
thing to have some
brief discussions but we're talking
about going through this bill
correlating it back to each other
option each other part of the um rsa
which you know is going to take an hour
mike and i'm just not sure
uh that's more of a work session what i
will
tell you is what i will ask you from a
parliamentary
standpoint if we have a bill that is
retained
and in the next two weeks we come up
with something
that everybody likes what is the motion
on the floor
to overturn can you overturn the retain
and ask for the amendment to an existing
bill is that
appropriately a parliamentary procedure
not from the house for what we could do
as a committee if the bill hasn't hit
its deadline
we still have the bill
we can reconsider them
and send the bill for the different
representations
as long as it's retained it'll never see
the health course
because we're not going to be meeting on
the house floor until
probably april 4th or 5th
but i just can't guarantee we're going
to come up with a solution
but there are other parliamentary
options that we have available
uh representative baruti yeah thank you
mr
chairman i i couldn't hear uh
representative seaworth but uh if if you
could come up with something
and we voted down the retain and then
come back with an author pass
on the floor i think that would be
quicker than
putting an amendment on a senate bill or
coming back next year
i'm sorry i couldn't hear uh
representative seaworth good he was kind
of mumbled
representative seaworth was correcting
me in that a retaining bill doesn't see
the house floor
and you can't change it the only thing
we could do is um
have the committee reconsider that and
so that's what he was just clarifying
representative rudy thank you
um mr chair yes
uh perhaps that's the the good option
to uh to work on this and then if the if
we feel that it's
viable all everybody in agreement then
uh move to reconsider and hopefully
follow with an otp hey
that's an option i would i would
agree to um as opposed to having to wait
for the crossover
any other comments
all right seeing none here we have a
motion on the floor
for uh to retain the bill
yes
votes yes warden
warden says yes sir trump
sure yes pro
yes yes
yes sullivan votes yes
susie susie vote yes
rudy rudy vote yes
cahill day hill votes yes
schmidt
sorry schmidt votes yes
to me give me votes yes
richard the chad votes yes
yes australia yes
yes
thank you um our executive session
is closed i have no more
bill's in front of us um however
michael i would appreciate it if you
could try to set up a zoom meeting for
either friday or monday with rudy ogden
in that meantime i will have all of our
concerns
and we can go through this uh the entire
law
and how it goes into everything how each
one dovetails into each other
and if all goes well you and i can
present an amendment within a week or so
for consideration thank you mr chair
i'm now open for public uh questions or
comments from the committee anyone in
the committee room
mr chairman
um thank you mr jim just a quick
question on going back to hb
501 do you guys have the blue sheet and
the numbers
on if anybody signed in support or
opposed
i'm happy to do so
nobody signed in except
oh wait a minute stop getting there yes
they're there i'm sorry
um 13 support to oppose
zero neutral one to testify which is tom
cronin and then miss reed
including our sponsor representative
kaiko
thank you very much
um our agenda is we will be coming back
um either probably not next week but the
week after
um to deal with 501 and anything else
that we have if we can go up an
amendment
um but i don't know if anything else
at this point representative i uh thank
you sherman i know you read it earlier
uh
i was taking notes at the time and
didn't hear it uh if i could get the
same
out for 517 i appreciate it
i've got it i have 501 or 517
going back to the original
yes going back the original date
of the hearing we are 189 in support
13 opposed to neutral
originally we had six people sign up to
testify
okay and a couple more
added on after that
any other questions comments of the
chair
seeing none thank you all very much
michael hear from you
tomorrow or monday thank you
thank you mr chairman